foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar addressing common challenges in
lentiviral Vector clarification using
closed automated counter flow
centrifugation system
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific and
Sartorius
to learn more visit thermofisher.com and
sartorius.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you're having trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
I would like to now introduce our
speakers Carl dargetz r d manager
selling gene therapy platforms Thermo
Fisher Scientific and Magda tamola
manager of testing Solutions and
analytics at Sartorius
Carl and Magda you may now begin your
presentation
all right well thank you very much for
the introduction and of course big
thanks to Magda and Sartorius for being
such great collaborators collaborators
on this project
um with myself and Therma Fisher so
starting off you know I just want to
take a look at the lentiviral production
workflow and of course here we're really
focused in
um on the clarification step because
we're we're looking at both
um two different instruments um that are
counter flow centrifugation systems that
are really um well utilized when used
for the clarification step here and you
can see that these are the the Rota the
CTS Rota counter flow centrifugation
system and the ksep
um the rotate of course from Thermo
Fisher in the case up from Sartorius and
so
um of course we're looking at the entire
workflow here and there's there's a lot
of important steps but as I mentioned
we're really focusing in on this
clarification step because that's what
these instruments can provide
um and so when we when we focus in here
there's a couple things that we looked
at much more closely to to see and show
how well they're able to perform for
this clarification step in your your
lentiviral production the first is
turbidity and of course this is sort of
um you know a macro look at how
clarified the the product really is so
it's you know very related to just you
know the the name of the step itself and
a very important measure of how well
you're separating out
um your cells from your viral product
um the next of course is even more
important because that's the actual
infectious titer so
um even if we're able to do good
separation between the cells and the
virus ultimately if you know the there's
some kind of issue in the processing or
um it's too harsh then you won't have a
good infectious titer once that
clarification is complete and then
everything Downstream will not work the
way it's supposed to so that's that's
really critical as well and then the
other aspect which is certainly related
to the other two is our VPC or viral
production cell viability and removal
and this like I said plays into those
other two factors but it's really
important because if we're again
treating the these cells harshly in this
clarification step then they could die
and release protein or nuclease or
excuse me um nucleic acid into the viral
product which can then have issues with
infectious titer QC all those types of
things so what this shows is that you're
able to and what you'll see is that
you're able to really keep the cells at
a high viability and remove a high
percentage of them which results of
course in that decrease in turbidity and
high infectious tighter
so moving on um now that we've looked a
little more closely at the workflow
itself I want to highlight some of the
clarification challenges that we face in
these types of workflows so the first is
the risk of shear stress you know during
that Harvest process
Um this can cause you know cell
disruption and lead to higher impurities
so again that really ties into
everything that I've spoke about so far
if you're able to treat the cells and
the virus gently then you should be able
to reduce the risk of cell death and any
impurities that end up in your viral
product so it's critical to have systems
and instruments that are capable of
doing that when you're looking at your
Landing viral clarification the next is
open process steps and you know things
with traditional batch centrifugation
which is you know the most common method
currently used for this clarification
step so you know it's clear of course
with with an open step the the major
risk there is you know some kind of
contamination from
um you know a bacteria or a fungus or
something like that that's always a big
concern you know you spend a lot of time
effort and resources in producing these
lenoviral
um products and so uh that kind of
contamination
um is a big risk and something that is
really reduced by having a closed system
and closed process for this
clarification step
um and then you know add to that the
fact that oftentimes it needs to be done
in batches which really kind of
increases the entire the total time that
it takes to do that processing and that
um you know is another major factor with
the continuous processing of these
counter flow centrifugation Technologies
you can really reduce the time by not
having to do these batches
um
in addition so the the quota the the
quality of the product and any kind of
um Lenny viral recovery loss
um which could you know be related to
the actual
um virus or just the the infectivity of
it itself could be related to shear
stress the total processing time so that
definitely kind of Loops back into those
first two points in a lot of ways
um but you know that's a that's a
current issue and a current Challenge
and something that really needs to be
continued to improve and I think this is
where we're highlighting some of the
improvements these counter flow
centrifugation Technologies can make on
the the current process
um and then finally there's you know
really limited options for ready to use
and fully closed
um Harvest technologies that will allow
for production at you know these some of
these larger scales
um with you know viral and Lenny viral
production of course you can get up to
very high volumes and so you need to be
able to
process multiple many different volumes
and things that higher volumes as well
and that again when you look at batching
um these things for a manual centrifuge
that can be a real problem as well so
all these are different areas where
um this counter flow centrifugation
Technologies can improve upon the
current methods of traditional
centrifugation
so now I just want to take a step back
and talk for a moment about how counter
flow centrifugation works this here is a
cross section we're using the Rota
rotary coupling here as an example but
it's very similar
um technology of course being both
counter flow centrifuges for the the
k-sep and
um there's really no major differences
from what you'll see here between the
two so this is exemplary of both systems
so
um as you can see here we have we have
the cross section and we're looking at
two forces that are interacting with one
another we have the flow rate over on
the left here with the kind of gray
arrows and the g-force of the centrifuge
with the blue arrows and these are
acting in opposition to one another
so as your cells enter through this
Central cannula you can see we have some
larger cells in blue and some smaller
ones in yellow once that happens okay
Enter The Cone and flow out into the
actual centrifuge chamber and so this is
where balancing these two forces with
one another
uh creates a fluidized and gentle cell
bed
um normally you know in a lot of the
applications we look at we're trying to
capture these cells for a downstream
purpose but of course in this case with
lenoviral clarification we're looking to
capture these cells
um and elutriate out the virus so that
we can keep the cells out of that Viral
product
you can see that with this technology
you know the the great thing is that
you're also able if you needed to to
loot trade out smaller cells however in
this case we're capturing all the cells
and the vpcs that we use will be fairly
uniform in size of course so it's a
matter of balancing those forces the
flow rate and the g-force with one
another to create that fluidized bed
while the small lentiviral particles and
media that they're suspended in will
trade out into a collection bag and the
cells are kept here and then they will
be harvested out into a waste bag later
so this is just to show the concept of
allutriation what is which is what we're
doing with the lenovirus but of course
we'll be capturing all the cells in this
example so again this is a really
powerful technology and Powerful
technique for linear viral clarification
um and so we'll show you some of the the
results from that in the coming slides
but I just want to review one more time
before we we go there the kind of
applications of counter flow
centrifugation in general we're talking
specifically again here about the
lenoviral clarification that you're able
to do that cell loading as you can see
in the upper left panel here loot trade
out smaller particles or smaller things
or just separate out the supernatant
from the cells which is essentially what
we're doing here since viral particles
are so small you're then able to perform
a media exchange or a wash something
like that so if you wanted to make sure
we kind of get all of the lenovirus out
you can do a quick wash through the
cells to make sure that there's none
sort of captured in that cell bed at all
and then
cell concentration capturing those those
cells so if there was some sort of Need
For Those down Downstream or something
like that you can Harvest those or in
this case most likely you're just going
to be using that as waste which works
perfectly well as well
so looking into the results here
um you know the first thing that that I
want to highlight and that we did when
we started looking at this application
was to sort of optimize the settings for
um rotate and of course we'll talk about
that later Magda we'll talk about this
for the case up as well but what what we
first did was look at you know two major
things to understand how well we were
able to do this clarification and that
was
um just adjusting the flow rate and
centrifuge settings and looking at the
viability
um which is normalized viability meaning
the change between the starting
population of cells and what came out
after the clarification
and then cell removal so how well are we
separating out the cells from the virus
you can see here we kept the ratio
between the g-force and the flow rate
fairly consistent and across the board
we're getting you know well in the into
the 90s mostly upper 90s from a
viability standpoint so we're really not
losing any viability in the cells and
then the cell removal is also quite High
almost all the cells are ending up
separated out from the the virus so what
this told us is that it's a pretty
robust method and it's pretty able to be
translated into multiple different flow
rates so this is good because you're
able to process at a higher flow rate
which means you should be able to tackle
larger volumes with that and it also
gave us the ability to you know see
right off the bat that you can have
cells that are healthy and not um dying
and therefore not adding to the
impurities of your viral product which
was um obviously very encouraging
so as we move on to turbidity you can
see here our pre-clarification this is
just taken you know directly out of a
bioreactor has a turbidity in terms of
ntus of uh over 500 and you know it it
does vary we've done you know a fair
amount of these production runs anywhere
from you know around uh 300 to all the
way up to 600 depending on the
particular run but
um in this case what we're showing here
is well above 500 and most of that
reduction occurs right off the bat just
with the Rota clarification so you can
see just a major drop all the way down
to 37.
once we do a filtration step we see that
drop even lower about around uh down to
around 12 but you know the the benefit
there of course is if you were to try to
just directly filter you know there's of
course the reason we do these
clarification steps um it would likely
clog the filters with with as much
um uh impurities as there are in the um
starting uh clarification product so
with rotate you know you're getting
almost everything done with that
clarification step it makes for a very
easy filtration step
um which is you know really encouraging
and we saw this consistently occur
so as we hop over to the cell viability
and Recovery again this is indicative of
the Purity
um and the
um just how well the viral product is
going to perform later we'll of course
go through
um the uh the additional results with
that but really what we're looking at is
is again normalized viability so meaning
the change in viability from prior to
processing with rotator to after and
then the recovery of cells meaning how
many of the cells we're able to keep out
of that Viral product so normalized
viability you can see clearly here is is
almost 100 percent so we're really not
losing any cells to death through that
process which means it's you know a
gentle processing which is great and
then by the same token our recovery here
is quite High we we saw a little bit
over 100 here which is really just a a
cell counting error so what this tells
you is that we're really not seeing any
of the cells going out into that Viral
product so that's really encouraging as
well so the cells are behaving well and
so you know that that again to highlight
how much um how gentle this this method
is on processing the cells you know post
um
post viral production these vpcs often
are a lot more sensitive than they would
be at the beginning and so the fact that
we're not really seeing a change in
viability and we're covering all the
cells is really encouraging it tells you
everything you need to know about this
processing technique
so finally moving on to the Infectious
titer and LV recovery of course when it
really comes down to it we can we can
look at turbidity we can look at the
cell viability and recovery and get a
lot of good information about that but
it needs to reflect the actual
functional aspect of the virus which is
the Infectious titer and so you can see
here that we did several runs
um to look at the the Tighter and
um when you compare the
pre-clarification to the um the Rota
um post clarification you can see
there's really hardly any change at all
so the the actual LV recovery for otaya
prior to filtration
um is is virtually 100 so we're really
not losing um any infectious tighter
between
um prior to rotea and post-rotea
clarification of course we do see a
little bit of a drop here after
filtration that's a you know of course a
known quantity something we would expect
here but it's really encouraging to see
that that's that's happening there and
not um through the clarification step
so with that I think I'll I'll move on
to the next slide and hand it off to um
Magda from Sartorius so thank you
thanks a lot Carl
um
hello uh good morning and good uh
afternoon to everybody also from
Sartorius side
now let me introduce to you the k-step
technology and let me also demonstrate
how powerful it can be for lentivaldica
clarification
so there are um a couple of
challenges in Lent travel Vector
manufacturing some of them are due to
the distinct properties of the lentil
valve Vector itself and some of them are
due to the manufacturing environment or
the requirements for manufacturing so to
name a couple I would say that
um
the sheer sensitivity often of the
lentaval vector and the reduced product
recovery due to loss of inductivity
these are major
problems and the case of comproflow
centrifugation really can address these
points by imparting really a low sheer
force while processing it's a really a
very gentle technology
working in a very similar way is just
described by Carl and I think this is
really the the the strength and the
power of of that system for
clarification
um looking for instance at another
challenge when it comes more to my
manufacturing
um so there are limited options actually
for ready to use and fully closed
Harvest systems to accommodate also
larger production scale processes
and these points are addressed by the
case set
um by a built-in scalability for
development and Manufacturing using one
of the same system and doing so in a
closed single-use manner
so let's have a look on the key
operating benefits of the ksep
so it's the ability to process a high
range of cell densities
um it can retain particles uh very well
particles such as cells or microcarriers
the low Shear environment definitely
and to name another I would say it's the
flexible operation so as you can see on
the schematic drawn on the left side so
you see the inside of a case at 400
instrument and the tubing set and you
see that there are four rotating
Chambers in the case of and
in during operation you have the full
flexibility of using one two three or
all the four chambers for centrifugation
and also you have the choice and you can
Define how many cycles of centrifugation
you want to do using one in the same
system and this of course is a very
important aspect when it comes to
processing a high range of bioreactor
volumes and looking into scaling your
process of course
so let's have a closer look on how the
case up really works more on a technical
level
so first you would go and install the
tubing and the Chamber set into the
hardware
you would Prime the system with a
suitable buffer and then clarification
can already begin
and now the typical cycles of cell of a
k-step processing start so the first one
is cell growth is loaded into the
centrifugation chambers and at this time
the cells are concentrated in the cone
while lentivial Vector is going directly
into the outflow
and it's um yeah it's washed out or
separated from the cells uh afterwards
the cells are washed and
um lentiful Vector is further collected
and this washing step is very effective
actually because the buffer can really
nicely penetrate the fluidized cell bed
so the vector recovery here is is really
good
and in the last step the cells that have
been collected in the in the rotation
chamber are discharged into the waist
and thereby emptying all the chambers
and making them ready for another cycle
of loading washing and discharging
so to optimize process parameters for
the case of 400 and for our Upstream
material we also did an um condition
screening in a very similar fashion that
was described by Carl before for the
rotia so also in our case we tested a
couple of different combinations of
GeForce and flow rates and we assessed
normalized viability and cell removal
capacity
and you see in the graph that actually
no matter which condition we used we
obtained very high cell removal rates
above 95 percent
across any condition that we tested and
also the viability was maintained very
nicely
also the data though applying different
settings was so the outcome of the um
the transfer was very comparable to
rotia data so very comparable also
between the systems
and uh now looking at
the condition
um 1003 and 150 ml per minute
so in terms of output it is very similar
to the other conditions we tested but
since it contains the highest flow rate
this in fact will impact the overall
processing time of how fast a whole
let's say 100 liter bioreactor
batch will be
clarified so this actually is the
condition that we recommend and that we
also use for further trials
for clarification of lenteval vector and
this is really
um to be considered when you are doing
as also scaling studies
so um and also in a similar way as was
shown for the rotia we see turbidity
data here so
um with the ksep we we are also
um
we're also reducing turbidity
significantly uh from pre-clarified so
crude broth material so
um the major turbidity reduction happens
actually in the in the case up so during
counter flow centrifugation
and when we fill the filter the
clarified Harvest we have obviously yet
a smaller but still significant
reduction turbidity most importantly
though is to please remember so both
steps are important so K step is really
nicely pre-clarifying the material and
the filter the membrane filter
afterwards is also needed because
um actually only after this step your
lentil valve Vector intermediate is
ready and it's suitable to be used for
further Downstream processing so you
would want to load it on a
chromatography column now or you would
want to do tff processing and the
material is uh very nicely suitable for
this
so in another trial we assessed the
operation with one or four chambers in
the in case of 400 as just explained
before we have the the options to use
different
um numbers of Chambers and when looking
on normalized viability and self-move
capacity again not only do we see hardly
any difference between the one versus
four chamber conditions but also on
absolute terms these um yeah percentages
look very nice and also still comparable
to rotia
um then we run a study where we were
assessing the repeatability of ksep uh
processing so what we did is we had an
um we processed five uh or we performed
five individual runs or Cycles with the
case app using one the same uh crude
culture broth containing the vowel
vector and as you see in the graph so
across the runs we were obtaining a very
comparable lentoval Vector Titus so each
one performs
um comparable to each other
um and uh what we did afterwards we
again filtered the Harvest the clarified
Harvest and here we do see a tighter
drop similarly as shown by carb for for
the rotia and this is also expected and
[Music]
um
yeah generally It's associated to
product loss um in the filter of course
okay so uh this is uh the final a final
example of a case of uh performance that
I am going to show it to you so here
again uh we assessed the one versus four
chamber operation of the case up to
clarify the interval Vector broth and we
see again a very similar results for uh
lentivar Vector Titus in the clear
indicated 400 clarified Harvest very
comparable so no difference whether
you're using 104 chamber we're also
seeing hardly any difference in the
titles of a case of clarified and
filtered Harvest
um and most importantly and that's when
you look on the graph on the right side
for Vector recovery so what we did is we
calculated the full mass balance across
the whole unit operation so from crude
broth to K sub clarified filtered
Harvest and here we obtained a vector
recovery of more than 90 percent of the
filtration and this is actually a very
nice result and a very good recovery for
a sensitive product such as lenteval
vector
so
um now bringing together rotia and kasep
and if you're wondering uh in terms of
scaling and if you're wondering uh what
would be the most appropriate
application for each of the systems
so we would say that the Routier system
can be used for low volume scale down
and characterization studies while the
case of 400 is to be used to process
bioreactor volumes of lentoval vector
Harvest at around 1 liter to 100 liters
and please keep in mind remember the
g-force and flow rate are the critical
parameters to be optimized across the
two systems
to conclude our webinar I hope that we
could demonstrate to you that
um counter flow centrifugation is a
um it's an Innovative technology
enabling a low sheer Harvest of highly
sensitive products such as slantivaro
vector
um counter flow centrifugation
allows for harvesting in a closed manner
using a single-use
consumables and maintaining High
infectious title
and the rotia system and the case of
they show indeed comparable performance
thus enabling an easy scale up in scale
down of the whole process or of the
clarification process
and since the end of the slide of the
presentation thanks a lot
foreign